vamos con el problema 154 en el problema
154 debemos determinar si x es negativo
x es menor que 0
ok la información que tenemos en el
inciso 1 es la siguiente nos dice que x
al cubo x 1 menos x al cuadrado x al
cubo x 1 menos x al cuadrado es menor
que cero vamos a ver qué nos dice esta
información que nos dice acerca de dónde
está x bueno pues vamos a ver donde cada
una de estas expresiones cambia de signo
x al cubo justo cambia de signo cuando
cruzamos el cero verdad entonces quizás
nos convenga a tener por aquí una recta
numérica
por aquí está el 0 por aquí está el 1
por aquí está el 2 por aquí está el -1
por acá está el menos 2 entonces
entonces 0 parece ser un punto
importante déjame marcarlo con otro
color con color azul entonces pero
parece ser punto importante porque ahí
esta expresión cambia de signo y luego
cuando esta expresión
1 - x al cuadrado cambia de signo a pues
justo cuando se hace 0 verdad cuando se
hace 0 que quiere decir cuando x es
igual a 1 y a menos 1 entonces estoy acá
y esto de acá el menos 1 y el 1 también
son puntos importantes ya con estos
puntos importantes podemos preguntarnos
en cada una de estas regiones una dos
tres cuatro regiones que sucede
observemos para empezar que en estos
puntos importantes no funcionan porque
justo este 0 o este 0 pero que se
queremos que sea menor estricto que 0
pero qué sucede digamos a la izquierda
de menos uno a la izquierda de menos uno
tenemos que este de acá x al cubo es
negativo
negativo y tenemos que 1 - x al cuadrado
también es negativo también es negativo
eso es a la izquierda del -1 verdad
porque estamos restando algo más grande
que 1 al cuadrado y entonces sería
negativo y aquí estamos elevando al cubo
algo negativo entonces negativo por el
negativo nos quedaría positivo y por lo
tanto esta región de acá no funciona que
sucede cuando cruzamos el menos 1 pues
éste sigue siendo negativo pero ahora
tenemos un número que hace esta
expresión de acá positiva nos quedaría
negativo x positivo y eso de ahí si es
negativo
estos son multiplicaciones entonces esta
región de acá si funciona entre el menos
1 y el 0 que sucede al cruzar el 0 pues
al cruzar el 0 obtenemos que ahora esta
expresión se hace positiva pero ésta se
quedó positiva entonces ahora queda
positivo por positivo lo cual es
positivo de modo que la región de 0 a 1
no funciona y luego cuando cruzamos el 1
al cubo queda positivo y 1 - x al
cuadrado queda negativo entonces nos
quedaría positivo x negativo lo cual es
negativo y entonces esta región que está
arriba del 1 también funciona y así nos
seguimos indefinidamente hasta allá vale
ahora con esto podemos responder la
pregunta de si x es menor que cero o no
pues no porque hay x que están por acá y
hay x que están por acá unas de ellas
son negativas y otras son positivas que
satisfacen esta desigualdad y entonces
no podemos determinar el signo de x
bueno vamos a ver qué nos dice el inciso
en el inciso 2 nos dicen que x al
cuadrado menos 1 es menor que cero
déjame factorizar x cuadrada menos 1
como x + 1 por x 1 es una diferencia de
cuadrados a lo mejor debimos haber hecho
eso allá pero bueno ya ni modo x + 1 por
x menos 1 menor que cero entonces ahora
como serían los puntos críticos de esta
expresión pues justo por aquí está el
cero por aquí está el 1 y por aquí está
el menos 1 y los puntos especiales donde
cambia de signo es justo cuando se hace
0 que son aquí y acá y qué sucede en
esos puntos pues a ver si venimos a la
izquierda de menos 1 entonces tenemos
que este el x 1 el x1 es negativo verdad
porque estamos sumando algo más pequeño
que menos 1 entonces éste es negativo
éste es negativo y queda negativo por
negativo que es positivo entonces
quedaría negativo por negativo que es
positivo entonces esta región no
funciona el menos uno no funciona porque
anula la expresión
pero cualquier cosa entre menos uno y
uno si va a funcionar porque cualquier
cosa entre menos uno y uno hace que uno
de estos sea positivo y el otro sea
negativo saleh es más se puede ver desde
aquí arriba si tenemos una cosa entre
menos uno y uno un número entre menos
uno y uno
entonces x al cuadrado es menor que uno
y si restamos uno se hace menor que cero
entonces esta región si funciona y a la
derecha ya no funciona porque cualquier
cosa mayor que uno hace que x1 y x1 sean
positivos y nos quede positivo x
positivo vale entonces la única región
que funciona es la que está entre menos
uno y uno ok entonces con la información
del inciso 2
tampoco podemos determinar si x es menor
que cero o no porque hay algunas x por
acá y otras x por acá que funcionan que
satisfacen esta desigualdad pero que
tienen signos diferentes bueno pero qué
sucede si juntamos la información de los
dos ok entonces tendríamos que x tiene
que vivir en la intersección de las
áreas azules entonces el único chance
que tendría
sería vivir aquí entre -1 y 0 en esta
parte de acá es el único intervalo que
tienen en común estas dos regiones
azules y en ese caso si podemos concluir
el signo de equis verdad si juntamos la
información de los dos equis queda entre
menos uno y cero y por lo tanto es
negativo entonces la respuesta sería c
muy bien y qué sucede con el problema
155 vamos al problema ciento 155 en el
problema 155 nos dicen que nos preguntan
cuál es la máxima cantidad de litros de
agua que puede tener la cubeta de mirena
entonces queremos saber los litros
litros
en la cubeta en la cubeta
cubeta de miren a migren
ok vamos a ver qué nos dice en el inciso
1 en el inciso 1 nos dice que la cubeta
en este momento tiene 9 litros de agua
tiene
9 litros y
y otros pues esto no nos dice nada
verdad o sea si nos dicen cuánto tiene
un recipiente no tendríamos por qué
saber pues cuánto cuánto puede tener por
ejemplo si yo te digo que me puedo comer
un sandwich eso no quiere decir que hay
pues yo pueda comer me muchísimo
sándwich o si me acabo de comer un
sándwich que me pueda comer muy poquitos
vale entonces si tiene nueve puede ser
que que los nueve estén por aquí o puede
ser que los nueve ya estén por acá y ya
llenen la cubeta esto de aquí no sirve y
en el inciso número dos nos dice nos
dice que si se agregan tres litros de
agua cuando la cubeta está a la mitad
entonces el agua de la cubeta aumenta en
un tercio
ok déjame llamarle a la mega la
capacidad de la cubeta hace para
escribir esto como una ecuación entonces
nos dice si se agregan tres litros de
agua cuando la cubeta está a la mitad
entonces si cuando la cubeta está a la
mitad
agregan 3 litros de agua
entonces el agua de la cubeta aumenta en
un tercio
entonces si teníamos se medios teníamos
medios cómo le hacemos para decir que
aumenta en un tercio
pues multiplicamos esto por uno más un
tercio sale este un tercio es lo que
aumenta bueno pues con esa información
podemos determinar el valor de cb verdad
simplemente necesitamos realizar las
operaciones déjame multiplicar por dos
de ambos lados del lado izquierdo nos
queda c + 6 es igual a del lado derecho
nos queda c por uno más un tercio muy
bien entonces c + 6 c + 6 es igual hace
más y más
c entre 3 ahora voy a multiplicar por 3
3 c + 18 es igual a 3
c3 se cancela con 13 restando lo de
ambos lados y por lo tanto se la
capacidad de la cubeta es 18 18 litros
salen en realidad pues encontrar la
capacidad hubiera sido una pérdida de
tiempo basta llegar a esta igualdad y
darnos cuenta que a partir de aquí
tenemos una ecuación lineal de donde
podemos despejar sé muy bien con esto
terminamos la lista de problemas de
suficiencia de información del game at
vamos a dejarle hasta aquí y nos vemos
en la siguiente sección a ver de qué
toca sale qué bueno que llegaste hasta
acá y nos vemos hasta la próxima